[Musique]
m
le festival bd but qu en version mini
rencontrer des publics éloignés de
l'offre culturelle dans les yvelines
c'était l'objectif dit ib des bucs ce
mini festival se posait le 4 juillet à
l'école de la deuxième chance de trappes
pour célébrer le travail réalisé par les
22 stagiaires six ateliers de trois
heures ont permis à ces artistes de
s'adonner à la création d'une bande
dessinée l'objectif c'était vraiment de
pouvoir créer différemment de pouvoir
développer son imaginaire pouvoir gagner
en confiance travailler en groupe créé
un objet collectif donc la bd
correspondait vraiment à ce projet
présent pour la deuxième année
consécutive l'auteur de bandes dessinées
marc védrines accompagner ces jeunes
lors des ateliers son objectif était
d'initier au dessin et à l'écriture ses
stagiaires souvent éloignés du monde de
la culture kanak ont pas dessiner depuis
leur plus tendre enfance donc
effectivement il ya un manque de
confiance à ce niveau-là dont je leur
apprends à dessiner des visages sur tous
les angles les proportions du corps et
il ya le trail de l'écrit c'est
intéressant le la bdc pas que des cinq à
l'écrit et à l'imagination et après je
les aide en fait à mettre en scène au
cices leurs idées
tania pratiquait déjà de dessin ces
ateliers lui ont permis d'améliorer sa
technique de création de visages et de
coloriage elle a participé à
l'élaboration de la page de couverture
la première séance on sait comment
dessiner et voir un peu nous niveau et
puis après on signé en groupe où on a
décidé de caen qu'est ce qu'on voulait
faire et de comment doit dessiner
après bah ça s'est fait tout seul sera à
mesure des choses on a eu des led les
stagiaires ont aussi pu voir le résultat
de leur travail dans un livre cartonné
franchement c'est vraiment beau puis
c'est vrai qu'au début je voulais pas
vraiment le faire une franchement je
suis je suis choqué
ce qu'on a vu dans les livres on l'a on
n'attendait pas ça et du coup c'était
bien et on est prêt cointat et on est
fiers de nous aussi
et si vous souhaitez voir la version xxl
de ce festival sachez que la 29e édition
de bd bucs se déroulera du 15 au 16
octobre 2022